all right New York Post has this report
cardi B hurled her microphone at an
unruly concert goer who launched a drink
at the rapper during a performance in
Las Vegas on Saturday becoming the
latest artist to have an object thrown
at them while on stage the New York
native had been performing bodak yellow
at uh dries Beach Club in Las Vegas when
a fan raised a white decorated cup and
tossed liquid in the 30 year old
rapper's Direction the rapper at first
was startled and visibly in disbelief
and then started and then decided to
throw the microphone at the woman now
I don't care about the story and you
shouldn't either but I do want to play
the video because there's one aspect
of this video that's kind of funny so
let's let's play it
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so the only thing you need to
notice from this is how the vocals keep
going after she throws the microphone so
apparently cardi B I don't know if this
is a ventriloquist
trick or something that she throws the
microphone and her voice at the same
time that'd be a great trick I mean
that's a trick you should take on
America's Got Talent that's that's
something
um so either that or she's lip syncing
on stage which of course is exactly what
she's doing now
this will come as a shock to some
younger people out there
but did you know
that it used to be a huge scandal
when musical artists were caught lip
syncing this was like a big deal
yeah entire careers were ruined because
of it
this had Milli Vanilli more recently
Ashley Simpson you know I was back I
don't know when that was was that 10
years ago or something is that dark spot
on your face still bothering you or what
about all those sun spots all over your
body is that bothering you too well it
should you disgusting freak now you can
watch them disappear safely and quickly
in three quick minutes Jenny sells dark
spot luxury system does exactly what it
sounds like those annoying dark spots
disappear before your very eyes
instantly smoothly and luxuriously
you'll be amazed at how quickly you'll
see results or 100 of your money back
guaranteed go to geniusell.com Walsh to
order a new dark spot treatment system
today and say goodbye to those pesky
spots tomorrow that's genucel.com Walsh
right now and save over 70 on genocel's
most popular package that includes this
dark spot system genocell.com Welsh if
you want some positive news in the
culture War since Roe uade was
overturned the left has lost their minds
making abortion their official Sacrament
the pro-life efforts which are more
important now than ever are booming you
heard that right despite the narrative
Pro-Line drivers didn't go away in fact
they have increased in numbers as one of
the largest pro-life organizations in
the world no one is in a better position
than 40 Days for life to end abortion in
each state in a post role America 40
Days for life is changing hearts and
Minds in the most blue pro-abortion
States they've had a record number of
locations since Roe was overturned and
they grew in both volunteers and
locations with about 1 million
Volunteers in 1500 cities they hold
peaceful visuals outside abortion
facilities you can help them fight the
ongoing legal Battles by protecting free
speech for their volunteers by giving a
tax-deductible gift of any amount at
40daysforlife.com that's
40daysforlife.com so Millie Vanilli and
Ashley Simpson they could have gone on
to become the greatest artists of our
time they had that in them I I believe
it I do uh who knows anyway but their
careers were destroyed when it came out
that they were lip syncing
and but these days it doesn't even make
a dent you know all these people are lip
syncing all the time and nobody cares
it's like it doesn't just it's far from
destroying their career it doesn't mean
nobody cares doesn't matter
um that was a for Ashley Simpson is
Jessica Simpson's uh
uh sister right just well and you don't
know who that is either if you're a
certain age but uh anyway she was up I
think she's performing on Saturday Night
Live and the track skipped or something
and and she kept singing and you could
tell that there was that she wasn't or
the track cut off and then you could
tell that she was listening oh that's
what happened
and that was an Infamous that was an
Infamous video it was a big I mean I'm
telling you it was a big deal everybody
cared about it there's the president at
a press conference everything was a
whole big thing the U.N was talking
about there's a big deal at the time
um and and yet in this video you have
the artist throw her microphone in the
middle of the set well the track
continues
which by all right should be a much more
Infamous video and yet it won't be
uh because all of these pop stars and
rappers and whatever they all lip sync
uh you go to their concert and you might
as well be listening to somebody play
their Spotify playlist from their phones
that's what you're doing it's like you
go to a concert and you might you might
as well just have someone hook their
phone up
and hit play on the Spotify playlist and
you just sit there and watch it because
that's all that's happening none of it
is real
even the voices aren't real because it's
all auto-tune it's all fixed with
computers now so nothing is real
and nobody cares
and I think it's because
back uh even 10 or 15 years ago and
certainly 20 or 30 years ago there was
still some kind of demand for
authenticity you know people cared about
authenticity and you wanted it you
wanted at least the you wanted at least
the the illusion of authenticity
but now there's no demand for
authenticity anymore nobody cares if
anything is written like not everything
is fake and and everybody's accustomed
to it used to it especially younger
people
and so it doesn't matter does it doesn't
uh
doesn't get any attention anymore
which is unfortunate
maybe part of the reason for that is
that everybody's High you know
everybody's stoned all the time hey
YouTube thanks for listening to the show
if you'd like access to my full show
with no ads you should go to
dailywire.com and use promo code Walsh
to get two months free on all annual
plans see you there